you don't hit a deposit enter deposit yeah now you just hit AFS to add filter
size if you do if if you do FS it will just do like filter size oh and then
enter to resume yeah it just resumes it how did I not know about well so this is
why we're doing this episode
best part of hacking when you can just you know critical thing
all right hackers the average is gonna get a little technical today so buckle up
for this okay I'm gonna tell you exactly how ThreatLocker is screwing
hackers at every step along the way with dynamic access controls
preventing even port scans from happening on ThreatLocker networks so
let's dive into it there's three primary ways that ThreatLocker implements this I'm
gonna give you guys two for this for this quick read and hopefully you'll be able
to understand how exactly they're preventing hackers from doing port scans
so first one is called local challenge this is on the common scenario where a
computer wants to connect to a network resource and they're on the same network
so what's gonna happen is over you know this this ThreatLocker handshake the
computer is gonna send a request to the server the server is gonna respond with a
challenge and then the computer has to you know complete that challenge and
provide a response back to the server before the SMB port is even opened up to
that specific computer right so you can't do any port scanning or anything like that
because you're not going through this handshake with the computer so that's that's
one way the next way is in like remote work scenarios where your laptop is like you
know out on some Wi-Fi or whatever and you still need to access network
resources in this scenario the computer is going to shoot in I you know authenticated
IP change up to the ThreatLocker cloud then when it requests access to a specific server maybe it's
trying to get in by like RDS or whatever if it's if it's in a remote work scenario the
RDS server you know before it opens up that port is going to query the allow list in the ThreatLocker
cloud and say hey this IP trying to connect what should I do with him and then ThreatLocker
cloud will give them a yes or no on that and they'll open or close the port based on that response
okay so with ThreatLocker in place really you can't even do port scans guys so tell
you what let's go back to the show and hack something easier and we'll let ThreatLocker
do their thing all right all right let's get all right sub hackers before we jump into the episode
got that this weekend bug bounty segment we've got actually quite a few items this week the first of
which is an exciting one hacker one has launched the nets killer program which is a really cool
opportunity for those of you guys that like to go after the you know asset note esque attacking
enterprise applications or appliances or whatever in scope is the nets killer gateway the nets killer ADC
nets killer AAA and they have treasure maps and credentials for each of these it's a public program
lows or 300 medium 600 highs 4,000 crits 10,000 not bad definitely something that you guys should look
at if you're interested in those sort of enterprise applications going after this
um next up is from yes we hack we have the ultimate guide to bug bounty HTTP request smuggling
vulnerabilities um like I've said in the past guys everybody has been sleeping on yes we hack
educational content it is super freaking good um so if you're looking to sort of uh clean up your
knowledge on HTTP request smugglings something that intimidates a lot of hackers from what I've heard
um this would be a great place to do it it's very thorough very long very detailed
um really good place to uh clean up your knowledge on HTTP request smuggling so we'll link that down in
the description um also uh this is coming from bug crowd uh there have been some changes to the request a
response feature in bug crowd um and this is when you know you need you need some feedback from the
program um and previously this was uh this feature was limited to one request open at a time that has been
bumped to two and you can request a response on submissions in the informational state so they're
expanding that a little bit which I think is cool right they are creating more overhead for themselves to
give you a voice right I just wanted to highlight that for you guys because I just think that's that's
good guy bug crowd um really caring about the hacker there in addition to that bug crowd also released a
hacker spotlight recently for Evan Connelly uh who is one of my favorite hackers out there um and this is a
great read as well if you're interested in getting to know uh the pastor and hacker uh which I think is a
really cool um personality that Evan's got there um so it's a good read I recommend it last but not least
um I wanted to point out a couple positions that are actually open in epic games now I collaborated
closely um you know worked with the epic game teams uh really closely in the past live hacking event
and um I got to know a little bit of the team and they are recruiting for some really cool roles one is
senior manager threat intelligence and offensive security um and the other one is ecosec programmer
intern okay um both of these are really good opportunities they're um located in Cary uh North
Carolina um and so if you're interested if you're in that area or you're interested about um hopping into
these uh we're gonna link these at the website um jobs.ctv.show okay jobs.ctv.show there we are right
there so we've got those on there I would definitely recommend working with the team they're amazing um if
either of those titles sound good to you all right let's go let's hop to the show there was kind of
two things one was I just think this is a really funny story for my daughter the uh I thought of it
when I saw myself wearing a black shirt today I was like oh I don't think I've ever told Justin that story
but uh we were at her cross-country meet and she was walking behind me talking with a friend and I heard her
say her friend asked like oh who's your dad or which one's your dad and uh my daughter sailor
pointed and said uh oh he's the one in the black shirt he almost always wears black he's a hacker
okay yes that's me yeah I thought that was funny kids kids are hilarious man I uh yeah uh one of my kids was
writing a little you know essay for school and she was talking about my job and I was like you got to
put ethical in front of hacker you know because they're like uh yeah my dad's a hacker he works
really hard at it he loves it you know that sort of thing and I was like their image is like me over
here like scamming people like right working really hard as a hacker stealing money and stuff so funny
and honestly like with the some of the bugs you found around css injection for like credit card leaks
it's like you could be legit at that but no yeah I want to do before we hop into the episode talk about
the life hacking event for just a second yeah um I don't know we since we're alive we don't have to
necessarily talk too much about it if you don't want to share but I feel like I had a self-realization
I just struggled with do I go solo or do I be on a team for the last like three or four events
and I have kind of just I don't know had mixed results or mixed success and then this time I was
like I want to hack with literally everyone like Justin's in this event Ronny's in this event Kieron
and BuzzFactor in this event a bunch of people from like Pliny's B Team 6 are in this event I want to
hack with really I didn't know that yeah there's like there's like five or six of them and half of
them have never been to live hacking event before and so it's really cool but anyways so I basically
just like didn't commit and then within one day of being in the event I was like I should have just
committed this is like such a struggle and it's so annoying and I think it's just my personality type
I know you are a big fan of like at least until dupe window ends solo hacking but I think it's just
100 personality related because what I did was I buddied up with like one of the more talented B Team 6 guys
who's never been to live hacking event before and it wasn't like he fed me the bug in fact he had
nothing to do with one of the bugs that I found but we immediately found two bugs one I found basically
solo but just like because I was like communicating with him and because I was much more energized and
excited about the event having like someone I'm hacking with I immediately found a bug and then we
found one together that was like like pretty incredible too and so anyways I think I'm just gonna
like stop trying to be solo unless for some reason I don't know I have to but I think that for me it's just like
I feel so much more motivated energized excited and work harder when I'm with other people so yeah man
I think I think it depends on your personality type and I also think this event is kind of like very
well aligned to your skill set and your your hype you know um so I think this could definitely be a fun
one for you to to play with you know and and at the end of the day man you know when we've reached
the point that we're at it's kind of like well I might as well do it for fun you know it's like it's like
what you want right we don't have to you know like I think there's a lot to being content and you know
a lot of value to being content and then you know making decisions that are not necessarily the most
optimized for winning the live hacking event or cash return you know but I had a lot of fun with my
friends and I found bugs that I'm proud of you know yeah yeah sweet dude yeah all right so that being
said we are in the middle of a live hacking event and uh and so we have some hacking to do today and
I'm realizing actually I am wearing the wrong glasses I don't know if you guys know this I actually
have special glasses for my ctvv episode that don't reflect oh that's cool yeah so I want to switch
into those but um yeah so let's let's get into the uh let's get into the meat of the content today so
we can get back because I was just telling you right before I got on this call I was like man I want to
hack so much right now I have a a psc exploit like primed and I haven't like and it's ready to press you
know test on it and I I'm waiting till I get done with this uh to test it so um it's gonna be a palooza
uh all right you want to you want to start out with um with some of the stuff you got or do you
want me to start with one sure yeah so I mean let's just set the stage real quick basically this episode
is going to be I thought this was a good idea I suggested it to Justin I again maybe it's a
personality thing but I'm just obsessed with like uh ways to make myself more efficient like I've just
kind of always been obsessed with efficiency and uh one of the best things I've noticed that I take
away from other hackers is basically watching them work anytime I'm screen sharing or collaborating with
other hackers they're doing things that are like oh wow if I had known that I could have saved so much
more time I would have like found more bugs I've been more efficient or whatever and I was like this
would make a great uh episode and I think you and Justin are you and Joel actually almost like a year
ago or a year and a half ago did an episode where you kind of talked about something light it was more
like kind of like scripts or like you know the best tool for certain jobs or something and so this will
probably feel similar to listeners to that episode but I think that uh cumulatively all of these like
little like efficiency hacks are going to make you a much better faster more efficient hacker because
honestly some of that boredom and some of that downtime can not only make you like like make you slower
but it also can make you lose motivation I don't know like have you've noticed that but sometimes it's
like if there's a barrier to entry to like doing the next thing oh yeah you always say reduce the
friction or remove the friction when there's that friction there you basically just don't test for things you
should be testing for 100 yeah you've got to figure out a way to optimize these things and I was actually
working with Matthias the other day on a bug Matthias Carlson and you know like before I even really
knew that they're like I was very confident there was a bug there he was like hey dude we've got to
automate this whole test process like you know like and I was like well I think maybe we should validate it
first you know validate this one pivotal piece first and then and then you know we'll go back and build
the the like you know um harness or whatever and like you know get this exploit testing um accelerated
and he's like nah dude I'm like really confident we got to do it right now and I was like all right like
I'll I'll do it and lo and behold you know like it would have taken me probably hours of I'm so close to just
validating I'm so close to validating it I was so close to validating it you know uh and I was so glad
that I had it automated that whole time you know so yeah I definitely think uh investing in that automation
pays dividends yeah because your initial attempt that you thought was going to work one shot it had
a little air and then you fix the layer then you fix a little air and it just keeps going right
yeah and each attempt takes so long that and I find that to be the case in this live event that we're in right now
because the setup is so onerous for some of these things to test you do have to set up like a big long
thing or you know and with a lot of um just ai related bugs I know oftentimes you're having to like
clear the chat or delete all your messages in the queue you know like a lot of these the things are
really difficult to do so yeah all right well let's jump into it um okay dude I I'm just gonna pick
on you right off the bat so your first one is even better auto decoding right yes okay dude so but
you know right by the time this episode airs I think kaido will have released the new convert
feature have you seen that I have seen you all talking about it I haven't used it yet okay yeah
so it's like a little drawer at the bottom of kaido that does like kind of what inspector does in burp
right yes um but it's got some additional uh nice nice features in there so um but yeah I totally agree
some sort of like auto decoding or something that allows you to see easier what you're working on
in an encoding environment is like super essential well so the reason why this came up I was actually
on a sales call with like with kaido and we were like showing it to somebody and you know they were
like you know they they asked if there was a plug-in the equivalent to um oh man what's the one where
you can use like custom tags in your actual request and burp hackverter because obviously that's a
really good thing and it's like no we don't have a hacker equivalent yet I'm sure we will pretty soon but
why have I not needed that and it was like really frustrating to me why I've not needed hacker and
I thought about it I thought about it and I even opened up burp and started using it was like I know
sometimes I have to edit inside of like url encoding and it's like oh even better just has the thing
here I just edit it over there it auto updates and then I resend the request and so anytime I need
to do like quick edits that way edits that way that's how I always do it and so anyways I just
wanted to mention that because I'm sure there are some people out there who are painstakingly copying
and pasting out of replay yeah yeah and I think for right now that is a good solution um probably by
the time this episode airs the new convert uh uh drawer will be available in kaido which is going
to have some really awesome features so I think that'll be one of the things that are is near the
top of my list but actually I've got a different solution that I use for that so this is actually
what I was hoping we would do in this discussion was I was hoping you would point out things that I
could do even more efficiently oh okay so this is just a rezzo like rezzo's like hey justin I've got an
idea what if we go on the pod and talk about you give me all your secrets yeah exactly just teasing out your
secrets here well dude I think it's also really awesome that I don't know you know how much the
community knows the history of your interactions with the pod but like you know rezzo was like
every episode as soon as it come out he would listen to it give us feedback you know send messages
like retweet and uh write it actually on on the like deck that we have when we talk to sponsors
like on the first page is like a glowing review from rezzo uh like if you're not listening to the pod you're
doing it wrong or something exactly yeah yeah and I'm like and we were working on updating the slides
the other day and we're like oh well I guess we got to take this out because it just looks like our
own co-host right exactly it just looks like you yeah dude it's great anyway what I was going to say
was um that actually what I've started doing is using the kaido command palette to do these encodings um
which has been pretty solid so uh I did a pr to um even better uh when was this like back towards defcon
I think and uh for those of you that don't know even better is like just like couple ui customizations
that sort of thing to kaido um and what the pr does is it adds all of the convert workflows to the
command palette and allows you to use them inside of your um repeater uh you know equivalent right for
those of you using verb um the the replay uh window so you can just highlight some stuff and then you
just press ctrl k base 64 and then you press enter and it you know basically towards encodes whatever you've
you've got um and so that's been really solid for me like I just it's something that feels really right
to use you know and like I don't really have to think about it I just say okay ctrl k basis for
ctrl k url you know and it just does it you know um so that's been that's been pretty solid for me but
I think that's I'm also going to add in there one of the things that I hope to make a pr for soon
is um also adding all of the named replay tabs in there so you can just do commit you know ctrl k or
command k and then just say like that one request and it and press enter and then it jumps to that
replay tab you know so yeah I feel like it could get busy and big re but like you know it might get
noisy but that's still a good idea oh for sure especially with the auto rename feature from shift
right like that's that is uh you know all of them are renamed to something a little bit more reasonable now
right um but I think I think that has increased the efficiency of my workflow a good bit yeah that's
awesome um so yeah you mentioned command palette from kaido um one thing I wanted to mention this is
like kind of uh almost silly but I think that it is going to probably help a lot of people who have
like never had a way to do this in the past in chrome dev tools you can right click on a node in
the dom and do edit as html I'm sure a lot of people already know that but it has been really
helping me in two ways one way is um there are often times that you're setting up a project or a
landing page or hacking together like some sort of like bug bounty tool and the like your um ai
assistant like whether it's cloud code or codex just can't like it doesn't know what's wrong or it's
trying to fix some ui or css thing and I've just realized that what I'll often do is go in there and just
like select like the the parent element like a couple parent elements up that is html copy and
paste in there complain about it and it increases the odds of a fix like very significantly oh totally
because it has like it has all the html and then and it's able to kind of correlate that with whatever
code is generating the html at the time um and then the other thing I've used it for is actually in this
live hacking event there are a lot of um scoping and policy documents and setup documents as I'll say it
nicely and um some of them are in an app where you actually can't download you know sometimes with
google drive for example you can set something where it's like not downloadable or copy and pasteable
and that was like pretty annoying to me because I wanted to give all that context to ai to like
start asking things about the scope or whatever just like help with like justifying um certain bugs and
stuff like that I knew I would need it throughout this event and so I just right clicked edit html copy and paste that
into an html converter online like there's plenty of html to markdown converters and then I saved that
off into a markdown note so that ai could reference it very easily and you know that whole process took
like three seconds whereas I can see some people struggling or not even being able to figure out how
to do it without like doing a screenshot or printing the page and then yeah yeah it gets complicated for
sure I think uh I think I definitely do that exact same thing and I and two two things that I wanted
to say on that that I've been thinking oh I should improve this in my own hacking workflow
is apparently now cursor you can hook your browser into cursor and it like has access to the page that
you're on and can look at the dom yeah I think it has its own browser as of yesterday yeah yeah yeah
it has its own browser too and um and that's just such a game changer for kaido dev because like now
literally you can just be like okay it's not centered fix it and it and it like oh I never thought about
loading kaido in there since kaido's browser based yeah yeah it can just look directly at kaido um which
is awesome uh so I'm definitely gonna have a lot of fun with that but the other one dude while I was
investigating what you were saying just a second ago I noticed this so um open up dev tools and select
like a you know a field or whatever right click on it and there's this like thing that is debug with
ai that has a little new thing next to it yeah you hit start chat and it just dumps it into gemini
in the dev tool nice that's cool so yeah I knew there was ai in dev tool but you would have to like
ask it about the element you'd have to like go find it that's cool that you can just right click on one
yeah yeah I think that could be really solid for like understanding you know why something is
operating the way that it is or um stuff like that I always also use edit as html to check I don't know
why I always do it but I always check whether like the less than sign is uh is actually url encoded or not
or html encoded or not or um html encoded or not because I'll see it in there and I'm like well
you know less than space is not a valid tag name so maybe it's not encoded you know but yeah it's
definitely encoded always so yeah that's actually interesting you brought that up because I've always
curious what how people did that who were like front-end people since it shows up as a normal
um angle bracket there yeah actually as we're talking about this I'm gonna go and do the thing that
I uh I was gonna talk about next which is uh the I actually have a set of tools that I use for like
client-side stuff um and I've got them on my on my web server under like quick tools is what I've got it
called um but essentially what it does is it I have like a set of tools that will allow me to just get
xss on my own page right I've got a set of tools that will do window.open I've got one that will do
a window.open in a null you know no origin I've got something that will iframe something I've got something
that will iframe and then like apply some sandbox properties I've got like some redirect scripts all of
that stuff is sort of bundled into a toolkit that I call quick tricks yeah uh you know and and I think
having those there especially like the window.open ones where okay I know I need this window reference
so I'm just gonna like hit it throw it into my window.open script I know that it's you know the
variable is always named j or whatever so I can like send a post message easily through through dev tools
or whatever um having those in place really minimizes the amount of time it takes for you to test
something um and then I've also got like this this test.html file that's got like a nice code mirror
editor like in it and then renders whatever I type in a you know uh iframe right beneath it so that
I can like very dynamically test how certain things are rendered or how javascript is affecting the dom
inside of that little you know debug environment. Yeah dude that's sick yeah I'm sure the community's gonna
beg you to release it now but well and and it well I I think I've released it to the critical thinkers
if not I will um but uh it also takes it automatically this is another cool piece is it takes the script
and it puts it automatically in the hash encoded so I was like if once I find the thing that I want
I can just copy it and be like yo joseph check this out and then it loads everything up for you and you
can see exactly what I saw yeah honestly there are probably other places where that um what's that
called where that like flow could be pretty helpful you know like places where like kind of like cyber
chef or whatever like anything that puts the content of the thing in the in the url bar or in or in the
hash um so that you could make shareability really easy if it's not like a massive mega script you know
yeah yeah in fact I was going to mention that so I'll go ahead mention it now but I still use cyber
chef sometimes like pretty frequently um recently I've been using it for like some AI hacking um not
for this event but just in general there are um often what are called you know queue params I think
I mentioned this last week on the pod but yeah and oftentimes if you have a query that's being passed
in as a get parameter and you're wanting to like iterate on it a bunch or like load it as like a csrf or
like or like basically test as like a one click um it's like a one click vulnerability you're like
very frequently having to do you know url encoding on your prompt and so I'll just have like a cyber
chef you know tab up and I'll just like edit my prompt and then I'll have it automatically url encode
and append it to the to the url and so then I can just copy and paste the thing at the bottom and it
just allows me to work like really quickly um so anyways if people haven't heard of cyber chef it's
definitely worth like playing with and using um it's almost always for me just like find or place
I often will also use it I don't know if you have like a it's a good question for you justin if
you're if you have like an http response that is like json um escaped um where all of like uh you
know your quotes are uh are all like protected and maybe it's all like on one line with like slash n's
like um or backslash n for new line characters how do you then like get it in like a human readable uh
view before you like are able to test it or hack with it dude this is a this is a you know somebody hacks
when they ask this question right like this is the real shit question that like that like only the
guy that's like damn this stupid like json encoding yes exactly it's so annoying to parse visually I
gotta go like put in cyber chef and that's what I do but I'm curious what other people do yeah um
so I've got a couple solutions for this sometimes I'll just like paste it into dev tools and have it
render the object and then like you know or do like a json uh you know parse on it oh interesting or
json load from from the um the dev tools uh but actually I've also got another toolkit that I that
actually integrates nicely into my next thing that I was going to talk about in raycast okay so raycast
is like the um I think I've ranted about it on the pod before but it's like a really awesome um command
palette tool for your os right so you you pop it in there um I've got a custom I've got a custom script
for it that I have bound to jeez I don't even know what I have what do I have it bound to I've got it to
windows key space um and then that drops me right into my like uh my tool and let me just read you
some of these tools that I've got so um in here I've got the following commands I've got cvss which
opens up cvss advisor for me to calculate that I've got pyd which drops me into a python console I've got uh
checks which opens up uh the the clipboard content in a hex editor I've got c edit edit which opens it
in a text editor I've got c command which pipes the current clipboard content into a command and then
copies it back out I've got cookie which takes the current http request that I've got and redacts the
cookies in the auth header oh that's sick right which is helpful for pasting stuff into the uh like a
report or into ai or whatever yeah I've got jwt and then I paste in the token and it puts it in jdp.io
I've got um url encode all which is different than uh url encode because I often want that yeah yeah
yeah and it's very hard to find stuff that will actually do it it's weird it does um I've got an ocr
one and then these are the ones dude these are the ones that are hype okay listen to this so I've got one
called mr which is just matching replacing the clipboard so I open up the command palette I type
mr space whatever I want to find space whatever I want to replace right so it's kind of like said
yeah exactly and and but it just does it but it happens on the clipboard and it puts it back on the
clipboard yeah you've told me this before yes so it's great I do this I do that exact thing with one of
the tools I was going to mention if you have more you can mention it but yeah I wanted to mention to the
the audience if they didn't know at least on mac os there is a command called pb paste and pb copy
and so I use that all the time if I have something on the clipboard and I want to do a match replace
I just like we'll have all over the terminal do pb paste pipe then like my said command and then pipe
and then pb copy and so it just pasted in you know it pipes it to the replacement and then it pipes it
about to the copy that's interesting you have the same thing in raycast yeah I've just got it built right
into raycast there so I can just do mr boom boom and and you're good right so I'll often use this for
like getting rid of new line characters or something like that in like a like a GraphQL query or something
like that right like for example if you grab a GraphQL query and it's got all the you know backslash ends
or whatever yes and you want to actually like see it yep um you can use the kind of plugin for that now
but uh if you want to actually you know just yeah have it in a text file or whatever and see it how it is
um then you can just use you know mr to to replace the backslash ends with an actual backslash n uh and
that will do it so you can tell it's a GraphQL query by the way it is exactly yeah you can tell
it's an Aspen by the way that it is I love that um but one more thing on this raycast thing that I had
was I've actually also got um I've also got a subcommand called text transforms and what it does
is it looks directly at the string that I've entered into my like custom command palette and if it's a q
w a s z x e r c or v uh it will apply that transformation to it so for example if I if I hit qq
that's going to double url encode you know q is url encode q is url encode right so it's going to
double url encoded right and then if I type qqw then that's going to url encode url encode url decode
right and then if I add qqwa url encode url code url decode base64 encode nice right so you can
create these like sort of muscle memorized um you know uh just strings that represent patterns of
encoding uh and then the system will just do it and then pop it right back into your clipboard that's
really cool yeah I like the way that you basically view your clipboard as like an object that can be
modified yeah yeah I think that's essential for for you know being able to automate these things
quickly I think most people don't though I would say most people paste it somewhere transform it and
then put it back but you're like just transforming in place which is really cool yeah yeah that is I
think that is a unique a unique factor there I also use raycast like native features like uh like quick
links and stuff like that for like a lot of the ctvb stuff that I go to pretty often and I'm really bummed
that gemini does not have have a q parameter because uh like I would love to set up like a custom gemini
uh command in raycast where I could just you know open raycast query gemini and then have it open up in
a new tab but it doesn't I've got something for you do you okay what what do you have a q parameter
for gemini maybe what are you dming me no that's somebody else okay I was like what the heck I'll message
you after the pod okay yeah that sounds good raycast does have ai built into it though which I do use
sometimes uh but I just prefer pure gemini I'm gonna rant for 30 seconds on this thing there are so
many um command pallets right now on my computer I have like there's like an auto pop-up one for clod
and an auto pop-up one for chat gpt atlas and I have one for raycast and then like when I'm in shift
it also has you know there's like I'm sorry when I'm in kaido there's like one for shift and there's a
regular command palette and um anyways my brain is a little bit um overstimulated with that um kind
of sort of on that topic uh actually it doesn't matter I was going to mention that I installed
omarchy on an old linux thing and I was trying to anyway it doesn't matter I'm just gonna stay on mac so
yeah what did okay no no no now you got it you baited me tell me about omarchy because I've seen it
it's just like arc it's like you say arch or arc I don't know okay it's it's our clinics but in easy
mode you don't have to actually configure all the things it puts you in like a default install that's
like already kind of sort of pretty and dhh and kind of invented omarchy it's really great um actually
I will spend another 30 seconds on this kind of um cool story because I feel proud of myself but basically
I have a my old lenovo laptop is dual boot um and the linux side is disk encrypted and I had ubuntu
on there and then I had windows uh installed on the other partition that I used to play minecraft with
the kids because I just you know sometimes you need windows yeah and um so when I wanted to install
install omarchy I was like oh I'm sure I can just pick the you know the ubuntu partition and it'll just
install great it did not and so they say on their website like oh if the uh omarchy default installer
like you use like an iso usb bootable usb it's like if that doesn't work then you have to install
it manually and all you do is you install arc linux and then you run this script that then like
customizes it to basically be like omarchy so then I tried to use the arc linux iso and bootable
installer it also doesn't work if you have partitions like that so anyways I ended up like manually running
commands to like um install it without the installer I basically installed our clinics from scratch without
an installer like without even using the arc linux installer and it took like two hours but anyways
now I have a marquee on on my lenovo and I'm gonna play with it sometime dude yeah you know I had a
season of like I'm gonna customize all my stuff and you know like it was was running that as well and
then I was like actually I don't want to do this you know like all I want is everything to work so that I
could focus on hacking you know exactly and reduce friction to hack yeah exactly so I just install you
know freaking out of the box ubuntu and just you know yeah or debian you know nothing something that
no blow and then just do it you know exactly yeah all right um let's see uh dude this one's a good one
why don't you talk about that one uh sure yeah can you how do you strike out in google docs you have it up there and it's so clean and I can't even find it in my ui I got you it's format
text and then strike third gotcha they need to make it as a quick button but anyway they totally do yeah
okay yeah I wanted to do it for these ones anyways okay guys yeah the one thing I wanted to mention
here because I still think there are probably not enough people using it although I'm sure some people
out there know about it is the ffuf dash request flag um ffuf is probably still my favorite tool besides
you know um proxy and um I still use it all the time and I think that you know wide scale
recon is a pretty busy place right now like it's hard to be the first person to find a domain and then
to fuzz and all the things and not get banned by you know nearly every company has cloudflare now
or you know something else akamai in front of it so you're often going to get rate limited and banned
anyways but one thing that I feel like basically very few hackers are doing well is doing content discovery
and fuzzing especially of like apis post authentication and some people are right
they'll they'll use automate or they're using intruder but it is not um trivial and often you'll
like quickly get rate limited or banned and when you're hacking on your own machine on your own public
wi-fi I feel like most people are just hesitant to do it because it's like if I get a WAF ban now it's
going to affect my ability to watch hulu or my kids ability and so I feel like people probably
aren't doing it as much as they could and should but one thing that makes it really easy is the dash
request flag in ffuf so you can just copy and paste an entire raw http request with your cookies or your
auth token if it's an api request and then I just like have my vps up in a terminal I paste the command in
I already have like a bash alias that uses the dash request flag with the file name like req.text or req
and so then I like I just always save the request as that file name and then I can just use my bash
alias to automatically use that file in the current folder and so now I can just like fuzz with my
personal quick hits list I have you know as quick and as easily as like oh copy and paste out of kaido
bam run it copies out of kaido and I could probably just write a kaido plugin that would just do that
right click ffuf this or whatever at some point but yeah it's already so fast it's like it doesn't
save me that much time to do that yeah you can actually do it with a with a workflow as well um
you know you don't even have to do a plugin you can just do an active workflow and that'd do it too
and you could launch that active workflow from the from the command palette uh but what I was going
to say was with this new version of kaido as well we they've got the save to file uh uh you know
built in now so if you hit if you right click save to file it'll drop it into the file and then
you can run fluff from there um so that that's an another optimization to that but I totally use
the dash request thing all the time as well that is like one of my most commonly used uh forms of buff
to be honest you know one thing I wanted just as like maybe a thing for the community or maybe this
could be built into kaido sometimes I'll want to um basically have a hack verter for ffuf you know
I want to like uh request with a file like a raw http file and then also have like uh you know the
payload that it's inserting in for the word list be wrapped in like a hacker tag so anyways it'd be
interesting yeah yeah that would be interesting I think I think uh yeah I'm wondering how
how I mean the way the way that kaido already automatically what's it called processes payloads
it's probably already the ideal way to do that um no I'm just talking about by default like you know
url encoding as a pre-processor oh yeah yeah pre-processors yeah yeah yeah yeah you could
definitely do that but I mean at the end of the day it's you know I mean kaido is rushed so you know I
don't know maybe it is faster than uh than buff but buff I think you know has been very optimized for
speed right um and yeah I don't know I guess it's not within my workflow to like use automate to fuzz
for something you know like you know do directory brute forcing it is for fuzzing actually but not for
directory brute forcing so maybe there's some uh some integration there that would be good like you know
you set up like uh your buff uh harness on the server and then like connect it back to kaido and and
have it you know you might even be able to do have it generate word lists like it does where it processes
the specific injection points like with a convert workflow or with a pre-processor and then goes from
there yeah I would be really neat if it came back and like dropped it in findings too if it like yeah
had a hit or something it'd be like a cool flag it's such a process though for me like typically
with fuff I'm I'll run it and then I'll see like okay you know every I'm not interested in anything
that's size 92 right now so then you do whatever uh fs 92 you know and yeah well it's afs right it's
like hit enter afs because you can add file size or do you control see it and then change oh I control
see it do you do you do you stop in the middle yeah there's a new thing where you just hit enter
you just hit enter it pauses it and then you just and it like drops you into like a little fuff um like
input input shell and you do and you do afs for add file size oh dude I don't have the new version of
fuff because I'm pressing a and it's not doing oh it's like it's like a year old you haven't installed
no it's it's like at least it's at least a year old yeah you just press a yeah do I have to like add
some sort of interactive flag on it no you enter deposit sorry oh you don't hit a deposit you enter
deposit yeah now you just hit afs to add filter size if you do if if you do fs it will just do like
um filter size oh my and then enter to resume yeah it just resumes it
how did I not know about this well so this is why we're doing this episode right even like
like you're obviously a top hacker you've used ffuf a million times you have a million hacker friends
but like these little tips can be like super beneficial yeah dude damn okay that's sick thanks for that
and you know what's crazy dude is I'm looking at this yeah I mean it definitely says
uh man I I should have seen that I should have seen that that's amazing I've wasted so much time
with that though yeah because you're like you're probably like hitting control c and then like
tacking it on at the end or something aren't you oh no it's so much better it's so much better
I just do I'll do um an auto calibrate but then you know someone get through or something I'll hit
enter and then just do afs because it'll it'll add it to the filter so anyways yeah but and dude
sometimes like my ssh session buffers if it's like you know 403 bajillion 403s and I'm like
press c c c c c c c c c c c c c and it's like well and then sometimes you run out of the of the term
history and you can't actually go back and see that one cool green hit you saw you know I'm talking about
yeah you get like a green hit then you get 403s you control c it real fast and you can't get up to it
wait what do you mean green hit hold up hold up hold up are you using like coloring too am I am I
like living in never use color in ffuf oh my gosh dude you're joking rep color no it's just dash c just
actually I can't you use dude okay visually parse for the for the character it's 200 without just seeing
green yeah I mean I do like I parse for bracket like you know I I T it and then I or like I pipe it to an
outfit file and then I no no way dude apparently I'm not a little power user no I mean literally
like five years ago when I started bug bounty and I was using it like freshly made ffuf to fuzz
um like verizon media stuff just like waiting just watching for the little green hits it's like tick
tick tick whenever it gets hits it's like such a dopamine rush for me yeah yeah it's I'm so shocked you
haven't like uh had that experience wow dude all right well I've got I'm gonna go read the uh the
man page for fuff after this because apparently I need to up my fuff game to be to be fair though I
actually don't use fuff very often like I mostly I'll use automate for targeted fuzzing inside of kaido
and then yeah you know when I'm brute forcing which is very rare uh you know maybe once or twice a week
then uh you know then I'll use fuff but um yeah still man once or twice a week I should I should I
should know how to use fuff damn it all right fine all right well hold on let me let me um let me give a
good one then since yeah do it yeah dude I have to give it give a shout out to uh jx scout I mean
we've mentioned it a couple times on the pod but I've started using it recently especially in conjunction
with cursor and uh it's pretty freaking great to have like yeah so tell me about it I don't know much
about it at all yeah so essentially what it does is it is it a chrome extension is it an app it's a it's
a um plug-in in kaido and the kaido plugin kind of sucks it's just like a hook for the uh command line
utility um definitely some improvements that could happen there but it uh hooks into kaido watches
your request history looks at your scope and downloads all of the js files beautifies them
puts them in a folder uh and then we'll try to like enhance a little bit too you know like uh with uh
source maps and uh you know trying to find other files to download and stuff like that um so you just
have vs code pulled up with that in it yeah I do yeah and I know that there are um there's other I know
that there's jas weasel and I and I think there's some newer versions of jack scout that I kind of need to
uh update to um but oh like to be honest it's it's so it's good enough for me to like just use it as
is and then just hook cursor into it because all I really need is the javascript files there beautified
and then ready for me to throw ai at it right and so then I'll just query ai and I'll be like okay you
know identify the pads I didn't you know pull this stuff out you know like and it'll just jump through and
read everything and and uh especially with the massive context window ais it's it's very good um
that's awesome yeah and you you just you know your js is there when you need it right you don't have to
go download it and stuff whatever it is it's there you know so I I think that's really nice it does eat
up disk space though just FY it'll eat disk space like um what did I say yeah I think like um so what do
you do if the are they often too large what's your go-to if it's too large it's it's not I mean this I
haven't run into that before with it being too too large um I'm talking about for using AI like like
let's say yeah you just always switch to gemini flash yeah I'm doing I'm doing targeted stuff anyway I
mean like sometimes I'll switch the model specifically to gemini or whatever but um uh you know a lot of
times I'm doing more targeted stuff like okay you know look at this block or or just the other day I
was like hey uh there's like this super weird um gts what is it it's glitter or something what is the uh
gts file no no it's like there's there was some weird file uh that was in embedded inside of these
javascript files where it's like you know calling functions with like bracket 40 comma you know I'm
like oh this is so yucky so I just handed it to AI and was like reverse this and give me readable
templatized js and it like plopped it out I was like oh god I love you so much um so yeah I use it
for that sort of thing I'll use it to say like hey you know identify you know the local storage places
or but to be honest man I often just use it for vs code functions where I'm like go to the function
definition please you know oh that's true just navigating around the file is huge yeah and then
in cursor I've got bookmarks you know I've got like bookmarks extension that I can use to like bookmark
certain parts of code and stuff like that to quickly navigate back and forth so yeah it's pretty solid
that's huge yeah js scout plus uh plus cursor plus the bookmarks extension really good stuff yeah I'm
definitely gonna use it now um I just assumed it was like js weasel or whatever like it was like
something kind of complex or something you had to pay for or whatever yeah I think I want to say that
yeah there is I think there's like a premium version of jx scout and um there's also a vs code extension
that you can use that will like parse the ast tree and like um identify paths and like pull a bunch of stuff out
kind of like js weasel does um but to be honest man like just having it downloaded and grabbing the source
maps and like you know doing its thing I think is pretty solid so it's like a command line component
that downloads everything there's a kaido component for the plugin then there's like a vs code extension
if you want to as well so there's lots of components sweet yeah um one thing I was going to mention which
is this is a super dumb but I'm sure there are some people out there who don't know about it I um uh
often in the last couple live hacking events or whatever have um seen or like just had a really
strong use for actually I want to talk to you about afterwards for this like school app that uh yeah
my kids use at their school but anyways I've just used the mac system-wide proxy um so I was going
to tell people how to use it real quick if you have a mac you can probably tell them how to use it on
windows but if you just go to wi-fi settings it's actually kind of annoying to find sometimes
but if you just like go to wi-fi settings and then click details next to the connected wi-fi
you can just set up like a system-wide proxy and so I'll just throw it you have to have installed you
know the kaido cert into your um keychain but you can just proxy the entire system and so that's a
lot of times that's useful if you're testing like a desktop app or just something that's more
difficult to proxy yeah hopefully there's not cert pinning man like like freaking have you had that
like um yeah I've had it yeah it's super annoying you know like like desktop apps and yeah it's bad but
yeah system level proxy is definitely helpful for hitting those those uh desktop apps and and it can
be easy wins too everybody thinks you know hacking these desktop apps are really hard if you can just
proxy it and then get to the apis then you're just web hacking again yeah exactly so yeah the thing
actually I'll go ahead and mention on the pod because I'm sure some people might be able to give us good
advice for it the thing that I was going to ask you the app that I want to test um because it allows
you to like see what your kids are browsing from their school which is just kind of crazy is is like a
http2 grpc and dude it's nasty it's really nasty it's like yeah there's one kind of doesn't support
http2 so I'm using like burp free edition but then uh the copy to curl from kaido uh doesn't seem to
work um whenever I then try to pipe it into burp um and then at burp you can't even really edit it
very well because you know how like when you're trying to actually edit like the bites the pain
for um anyways this is a really weird protocol uh but I almost could guarantee it's going to be
vulnerable and I you know I feel like impact on seeing what kids are browsing to on their computers
like being able to see what all the students are browsing to is such high impact and I just care
about so I care about securing it for my kids so exactly yeah totally man I I think http2 you know
right now did you try a downgrade like does it does it support http1 if you downgrade it or it doesn't
yeah that's whack yeah I mean then you're stuck using using burp there uh but yeah I think that
one of the things that I have had success with though is is getting a like if you if you can get ai to
um poke at yeah to like get there that's true I should I should have had ai used python to do it
it would probably be a lot cleaner like hey here's my token you poke at this yeah exactly yeah yeah um
so might go after that okay um we've only got a couple more minutes but uh I was going to mention
dude I know matan pointed this out in his episode that we did and so a lot of the like die-hard listeners
have heard it but I'm going to repeat it again for everybody conditional breakpoints in dev tools
are massive like one you don't need to be pressing you know next next next next next next every single
time you're trying to set like a breakpoint and load into something um and you can use conditional
breakpoints not only for their actual purpose which is can you know conditionally triggering a breakpoint
but you can use conditional breakpoint to run arbitrary js code at a specific spot in the execution
script without having to use match and replace and dealing with like you know I know a guy that's
been using that for testing feature flags yeah it's uh it's yeah uh what who's that guy you know
who that guy who could that guy possibly be um but I use it all the time for testing feature
um and it's just very helpful right because feature flag stuff there's always a function that's
parsing the feature flags and being like should I turn this on should I not and you just say like
yes for everything um so the way that I do it is typically like you know use um parentheses or whatever
and then put whatever you want to do comma false so it just returns false uh always which is which
will not trigger the conditional breakpoint but it does run the js code um and I just you know it's
hacky it's it's messy but that's the kind of we like you know like and it gets the job done really
quick when you need to run some js code at a specific point um yeah how do you I I still find devtools
um breakpoint system to be like confusing and annoying like sometimes they all disappear sometimes
they don't get triggered it's like yeah yeah no it's a pain and then sometimes you you use the little
like disable all breakpoints button and then it still does it like it still breaks on them I'm like
frick stop you know and then I got to go in there and like uh you know delete all of or uncheck all the
breakpoints with the like uncheck all button and then I disabled the one that I wanted and it's like
that interface could really really use a facelift in my opinion yeah cool you want to rapid fire these
last few yeah okay so rapid fire um all right you next go all right cool I'll rapid fire both of mine and
and then you can clear out your list okay I for this event um did something pretty cool chat gpt atlas
is like good enough where it's like actually usable and I've heard perplexity comment comment
is actually like more than usable like pretty fast and like basically doing things in the browser
and so like for hacking it's kind of useful kind of not but what I found it to be really useful for
and I think other hackers will too is basically setting up things so like let's say
you're trying you're trying to like set up a new um I'm trying to think of like an example of stuff I
have a hack uh or like thing anyways where you're trying to set up a new sass or like let's say okay
actually here's a great example you're inside of gcp right and you're trying to set up some new service
and you're like confused and you're annoyed you don't really care and you know whatever you like
open up chat gpt atlas and say hey here you're inside my gcp account don't do anything that's going
to cost me a bunch of money but go spin up a vm or whatever or go enable this service right and it's
like it'll it'll do its own research it'll browse around it can click around it can kind of figure
it out for you which is really cool and really useful there probably are some implications for
like crawling a site more intelligently than just like using katana that you could also use this for
if you were proxying but anyways i thought that was i thought that was really cool second thing is um
a completely different tip which is terminal notifier there's probably an equivalent on windows
but there's this mac thing called terminal notifier and it gives you like a notification
i um in my system prompt for codex and cloud code have it use a terminal notifier whenever it's done
so it like can ping me and let me know that it's done working because i find myself getting distracted
and like an hour later i'm like oh crap i had this thing writing code for me in the background and it
now has asked me a question and i want to know about that question um i think there's also like
basically a way to like they're called hooks where you can hook in where it doesn't even have to choose to
notify you it just like always run some snippet of code when it's at like a stopping point i'm pretty
sure they're called hooks if anybody wants to look into that anyways those are just two tips i wanted to
bring up yeah are you talking about when the command is done running or are you talking about when it
hits like a pause point um both but specifically a pause point oh really yeah the pause point is
interesting i i i haven't found anything that does that uh i have used like something like notify sh or
project discoveries notify to like get like a you know discord ping or whatever when my thing's done
or i actually had an alias on one of my laptops i don't think i transferred it over but it would go
beep you know i could just say like pipe it into beep or like and and beep and whenever it was done it
would go beep you know daniel measler has one that uh pipes it into another ai which summarized what it
did and it immediately talked to him out loud at his desk so it'll just like it'll be like i just completed
the task that you gave me it appears as if this task has been completed here is the summary so
exactly exactly all right thanks jarvis um yeah dan would have jarvis um all right do you have a hard
stop right now or can i rapid fire these you can have fires okay i'm gonna rapid fire these um i talk
about kaido a lot so this is mostly for the people in the kaido ecosystem because i am in the kaido
ecosystem and that's what i hack with so that's what you're gonna get but you can also think about how to do
these things in burp if you are not using kaido also jx out that i mentioned earlier does have a
burp extension as well um okay so top level navigation highlighter i cannot like say this
enough i know i've said it time and time again you guys are probably sick of hearing me say it if you're
not using this you are in the stone age like it's it's on by default i think i don't know that they
turned it on by default because people were like people you know i think they turned it off it was
definitely on by default for a while i used what was it okay yeah you got to be using color navigations
in kaido as a password that is just non-negotiable at this point like it is just so much better okay
so you will be able to navigate so much quickly so much more quickly at the very at the very least it
is installed into kaido it might not be enabled but you just go to pass workflows and you enable it and
then anytime there's a top level nav in your browser it'll get highlighted specific color and it's it
helps just like bookmark what you're doing too even if you're just scrolling really fast through history
and you're like what was i doing your eyes will jump to those colors and get able to find requests so
much faster yeah that was uh that was five top level navigations ago you know like okay i it just
gives you much more you understand where things are in hp history much better um next is shift which
we've talked about before but i went through my shift queries and i identified what i most use
them for and here they are um adding quick and dirty match and replace rules is number one i do that all
the time with shift i never use the matching place interface anymore i just tell shift to do it
uh generating quick word lists with specific things that i want in them so you know you know one to
a hundred line wordless um justin was typing that out he actually said quick workouts so apparently
he uses shift to generate his workouts as well dude why are you watching me type in the doc man i'm like
listen all right give me like give me like tabata you know give me like a tabata thing to to do oh my
gosh dude i sound like an i just said tabata in english and that sounded horrible oh gosh i don't
even know anyways anyway uh it's it's one of those like hit workouts right so you know you can do like
you know burpees lunge jacks you know those right yeah tabata yeah oh is that how you say it in english
i think that's how you say it in english i've never heard in any other language yeah well anyways that
makes sense more shift tips okay um i use it to mass modify json so hey you know add some tags here
you know modify the casing here you know do that um i use it to generate uh hpql queries and i use it to
update filters so those are the main um uses that i use to shift work um drop is super helpful and
expedites the workflow a ton if you are collaborating with people super easy to set up super clean um
definitely use it uh and then the last one that i'm going to do is because everyone for literally
everyone's still on the stone age they're literally copying and pasting raw http into discord then the
person has to copy it then they have to send a natural request because otherwise you know in burping
kaido both whenever you paste it in you have to set the host header and so it's like um normally what
i always do and i'm sure you do this too you go find a similar request that you know is to the same
host which is sometimes annoying and also costing you time to send the replay so that when you paste
it in you don't have to edit the host editor right exactly so now you can just right click drop it to
justin so much easier so much freaking easier dude drop is beautiful drop is really beautiful um
and then last but not least there's dev tools so for any uh in in kaido okay so this is not the dev panel
uh you know that you see in the browser this is a hot reload script in kaido that reinstalls your
plugin every time you push code changes if you're not using this when you're doing kaido dev i don't
know how you're doing it because it's a pain to manually reinstall and uninstall the plugin every time so
um those are our hacking workflow tips for you guys hope you enjoyed that i know it was a uh
little bit of a rapid fire episode with a little bit here a little bit there but um yeah and i i guess
these things have really made a difference in my hacking workflow and i learned a ton as well from
you rezo today i'm so excited for that for that pop stuff yep yeah dude yeah i'll have to show you later
all right sounds good thanks guys ready to bounce all right yeah peace peace guys and that's a wrap
on this episode of critical thinking thanks so much for watching to the end y'all if you want more
critical thinking content uh or if you want to support the show head over to ctbb.show discord you can
hop in the community there's lots of great high-level hacking discussion happening there on top of
master classes hack alongs exclusive content and a full-time hunters guild if you're a full-time hunter
it's a great time trust me i'll see you there